sex for men is one of the maybe it is
the most potent motivator in the
universe there is nothing that tops it
and so in a world where women guard
their reproductive capacity carefully
because they do not want to accidentally
produce a child for which they will be
fully responsible for raising it
men have to live up to whatever standard
women set in order to be worthy of a
sexual relationship which is the
ultimate goal of the evolutionary
exercise
that was a coherent world not fair but
coherent
you introduce birth control in which sex
and reproduction are now technologically
separated from each other and that logic
no longer works